vous venez de faire un nouveau dinosaure
ouais c'est un peu ce que nous faisons ici l'
exposition s'ouvre au public dans trois
semaines mr.  masrani voulait que je vous
consulte vous voulez consulter ici ou dans
mon bungalow ce n'est pas drôle petit drôle
nous aimerions que vous évaluiez le paddock
pour les vulnérabilités pourquoi moi je suppose mr.
masrani pense que puisque tu es capable de
contrôler les Raptors tu vois tout est une question de
contrôle avec toi Je ne contrôle pas les
Raptors c'est une relation c'est basé
sur le respect mutuel c'est pourquoi toi et moi
n'avons jamais eu de deuxième rendez-vous excusez-moi je
n'ai jamais voulu une seconde  Prince un
itinéraire pour une soirée Je suis une
personne organisée quel type de régime
ne permet pas à Kela tous en
fait et quel genre d'homme se présente
à un rendez-vous en short de bain Amérique centrale
ce n'est pas bien d'accord pouvons-nous  concentrez-vous simplement sur
l'actif, s'il vous plaît, regardez l'actif, je comprends que
vous êtes en charge ici, vous devez
prendre beaucoup de décisions difficiles, il est
probablement plus facile de prétendre que ces animaux ne
sont que des chiffres sur une feuille de calcul, mais
ils ne le sont pas, vous êtes en vie  Je suis pleinement conscient
qu'ils sont vivants, vous avez peut-être fait d'eux un
tube à essai, mais ils ne savent pas
qu'ils pensent que je dois manger, je dois
chasser, je suis sorti, vous pouvez vous identifier à au
moins une de ces choses.